John what surprises you more that Zach
Braff was able to raise over two million
in under five days on Kickstarter or the
backlash she's receiving for doing it I
would say the backlash because zach
braff raising two million dollars and
five days on Kickstarter that doesn't
surprise me you know what's interesting
is that to me people that I know have
been saying for years a couple years
like we can't wait until bigger
celebrities get involved because they'll
bring a whole new audience into this and
make people more comfortable and used to
doing crowdfunding and to me that is my
opinion of it it's like I don't really
understand the backlash actually to me
it's like to me the backlash I don't
even understand the backlash because
like really what does it hurt for
someone like that to do this you know um
you know because it's like oh well he
has enough money to pay for an honest
own well why you know why should he you
know why not engage your fans and give
them ownership over what you're doing I
mean I don't underst baffles me you know
why anyone would be opposed to this
because for the whole community it's a
good thing because you're bringing more
people into the Kickstarter community
just like Veronica Mars as well and
granted those people are specifically
those people's fans and aren't going to
translate into other people but once
they get used to it they might look
around you know not everyone but even if
ten percent of those people who never
did a Kickstarter campaign or
contributed to a Kickstarter campaign
look around for other projects you know
and if one percent of if ten percent of
those people contribute you know that's
a win you know I think you know what's
ironic is that people complain about I'm
sick of getting hunted hounded for
crowdfund campaigns it's like the same
group of people hounded over and over
again but by the same token when these
two campaigns come out that expand the
reach of crowdfunding everyone
and moans about it and to me you know i
have to say that you know being a
filmmaker as well
I'll say filmmakers are a group of
people who like to complain you know and
that was the thing that always struck me
about film school what we would do is
sit around the halls and complain about
film school you know and then when
you're out of film school you complain
about something else and then it's
something and I think it goes to
filmmakers being and you have to be kind
of critical to be a filmmaker you have
to be to make a good film you have to be
critical of your own work you know you
have to there's something about that and
so you know maybe you can tell me what
some of this i mean i've read some of
the blogs but they still seem so stupid
to me you know some of the sentiment
that i've heard is that you know
kickstarter indiegogo and platforms like
that should be kind of for quote the
people that you're supposed to be an
indie artist and I get that but then
what is there like a litmus test as to
what that's indie like it's a very small
like I would have to say that I think
those are the Indies the indie people
who are saying that Kickstarter and
IndieGoGo are for indeed people you know
it's like a you know the people who
think that indie stuff is only for
Indies or people who are complaining
that they can't make a living you know
and the way that you should function as
an artist is to be as inclusive as
possible as to who your audience is and
want to constantly expand that audience
into people why wouldn't you what why do
you not want to engage more audience and
expand your audience and to have other
people possibly seeing what you do and I
Zach Braff again it goes to the thing
it's like to think that Zach Braff
coming in and doing a Kickstarter is
going to hurt you means that Kickstarter
is a zero-sum game and it's not a
zero-sum game it's it's not you know
it's I don't know the statistical
analogy of what the opposite of a
zero-sum game is so but all I know is
that by someone giving the zach braff
does it mean that your small little
project is going to get one less funding
person you know it doesn't work like
that it's not this finite pool of money
that you know this person has or this
person has what you have to do in
crowdfunding is find your audience
and encourage them to engage with you
and if you're not doing that then you're
not going to succeed and zach braff has
nothing to do with that and there's your
saddle quote let me notice your sound
bite that and that's I should write that
down you know but he has zach braff has
nothing to do whether you're engaging
your audience effectively you know
that's your problem you know and you
know what I think is interesting is that
you know I think more and more
celebrities will do this for their pet
projects and I think that's a good thing
and I think filmmakers can learn from
that and see you know because a lot of
what I think what's crowdfunding is
moving away from a merchandise platform
to an experiential platform and to me in
a sense it's not what's key and that is
that it's it's a scarcity platform in a
sense that you're selling scarcity and
that in the world of digital of a world
of abundance is what it becomes valuable
is what is scarce and so certain kinds
of merchandiser scarce and you can make
them scarce and those have a chance of
doing well so long as you are smart
about like making something that your
audience wants but you are also smart to
create experiences and who is I just
talking to about their campaign yeah I
was talking to a filmmaker who is
actually in the ATV summit so is my pre
consultation with them and they have a
band involved in the film and I think
what's really interesting is that you
can create these different levels of
experiences again from the music model
and value those to allow consumers to
engage the level that they want to
engage and are able to engage in and
that you know you'll have some really
high end rewards a super VIP package
that only certain people will be able to
afford but what crowdfunding allows you
to do is to engage in those tears and so
you can still create a smaller end
package where someone can come
to you know get a standard VIP pass come
to a screening go backstage you know and
meet the band for however long but then
you can do a super VIP package where
they actually have dinner with the band
and filmmakers before or after the
screening you know why not you know and
I think these are all just I think we're
still in a kind of experimental mode of
how this new form of engagement and
financing and marketing is all going to
work and I don't think it's right for
anyone to say some people can come to
the party and others can't what you know
you're going to see is when crowdfunding
expands beyond art and where any kind of
when small businesses start using
crowdfunding and again why not you know
the banks don't supply funding to small
businesses you know so you know it would
be it'll be wise for small businesses to
start up any kind of business to start
up and start and to use that and they do
it in indy gogo all the time Kickstarter
is limited to art but IndieGoGo you see
all kinds of small businesses doing
different things and so what's the
difference yeah snaily it's enough I
mean the hall again the whole issue is
to me it's a non-starter it's like it's
just a bunch of people want to complain
you